foreign
I've never known life without disability
disability is where a physical or mental
condition or impairment is combined with
physical or social barriers that make it
hard for a person to do certain things
or interact with the world around them
disability is very diverse with a wide
range of experiences that can affect a
person's ability to see move hear learn
communicate or interact with others
in my case my sister Aaron is autistic
and has intellectual disabilities
she processes the world differently
she enjoys riding her bike collecting
rubber ducks watching YouTube videos on
repeat and spending the money she earns
at work when she's really happy she
squeals and flaps her hands
though for many people Aaron is
different she is my normal in my family
we were raised with the core value that
different is not less
but it was made clear to me that the
rest of the world did not always share
this value like I'll never forget one
time in Middle School my sister's aide
had made a video of her learning how to
communicate using speech and sign and
thriving in an inclusive classroom where
she was loved and accepted just for who
she is
and I brought it to school wanting to
share to give my classmates the
opportunity to learn more about autism
only to be told by my teacher that the
faculty had decided against it to
protect me from other students
inevitably making fun of her
it was one of many instances that taught
me what stigma was with every rude
comment when Aaron would have a sensory
meltdown in a public place with every
casual use of the slur [ __ ] by even
childhood friends of mine with every
judgmental stare I learned that the rest
of the world didn't necessarily see
Aaron for the full human being that she
is
now when I went off to college I didn't
know what role if any disability would
play in my life outside my family
it wasn't until I studied abroad in
China for my international relations
major that my personal background with
disability and my career came together
through a class I was taking on social
issues in Beijing I had the opportunity
to visit an Autism school there and was
introduced to a local disability rights
advocacy organization
I ended up interning with them and got
completely absorbed into that Community
I was finally able to see how my
family's struggle was part of something
much larger and the magnitude of what I
found actually shocked me
over a billion people an estimated 15 of
the world's population has some form of
disability
and persons with disabilities as a group
worldwide face huge amounts of stigma
and disadvantage like just to use
education as an example of the 240
million children with disabilities in
the world about 50 percent have never
been to school
I was appalled that I had been studying
Global human rights at an Ivy League
school and even though the problem was
so unbelievably huge not once had
disability really ever come up so I
decided to Pivot and I've spent the past
decade in my career to disability
inclusion in International Development
I returned to China on a Fulbright
scholarship to do research on education
and programs for autistic adolescents
and adults I then went on to do research
or work with disability organizations in
places like Tanzania Ireland and South
Africa I now work globally with Special
Olympics using sport as a platform to
teach and promote inclusive attitudes
and what I found is that all over the
world even though countries specific
cultural contexts or systems might be
different the underlying problem of
attitude barriers Remains the Same
and the research backs me up the second
most cited barrier to inclusion after
lack of data is negative attitudes
towards disability what people don't
realize is that exclusion hurts everyone
the international labor organization
estimates that disability exclusion
costs low and middle income countries
between three and seven percent of GDP
but the opposite is also true inclusion
could help everyone our research at
Special Olympics has found that
inclusive Sport and youth leadership
programming has benefits for youth both
with and without disabilities especially
when it comes to developing key social
and emotional skills everyone needs to
succeed in an increasingly diverse and
interconnected world and this is held
true in countries as different as the
United States China India Kenya and
Greece
the good news is there are four things
we all can do to make the future more
inclusive
number one we need to reevaluate our own
attitudes towards disability I still get
questions about whether it is realistic
to include persons with disabilities in
International Development programs when
even the so-called regular people are
struggling there's still too many
stereotypes that associate disability
with pity and we're still living with
social systems and physical structures
that segregate people with disabilities
so fewer people have it as part of their
everyday experience and it still makes
them really uncomfortable
we need to reevaluate these attitudes
needing accommodation or support does
not make a person any less deserving of
dignity and respect this is a matter of
justice and Equity not charity
second choose to include solving this
issue is not just a matter of policy
there are plenty of countries that have
disability laws on the books or if
signed and ratified the United Nations
convention on the rights of persons with
disabilities but there is still a huge
gap between what is written in policy
and what actually happens in practice
and this comes down to all of us we can
put pressure on governments to make sure
that laws are actually implemented but
we can also look at where we have the
power to affect change we should be
looking at organizations diversity
equity and inclusion strategies and see
where we can be doing better too often
we still fall short of recognizing
disability as part of human diversity we
would all benefit by not only
accommodating but actively supporting
and including persons with disabilities
in the workplace
third we need to recognize where
disability intersects with every issue
area when we talk about gender Equity we
need to be inclusive of women with
disabilities who are actually more
likely to be victims of gender-based
violence when we talk about global
health and Health Systems we need to be
inclusive of persons with disabilities
who are more likely to have poor health
outcomes often not because of their
actual disability but because of stigma
and lack of access to care everyone has
something they can do to make their work
more inclusive and together these
Collective efforts can result in the
cultural shift that we need
finally and most importantly don't just
listen to me listen to persons with
disabilities themselves
all over the world there are incredible
self-advocates like my friend and
colleague Ben who is both legally blind
and has intellectual disability and who
successfully advocated to the D.C
Department of Transportation to get
voice and sound added to the crosswalks
near our office to make it safe for him
and people like him to cross the street
going to work or Brina from the
Philippines whose parents were told upon
her down syndrome diagnosis that they
shouldn't set their expectations too
high but who has become an assistant
preschool teacher and a UNESCO Champion
for inclusion in education or hasib who
has actually been on a tedx stage before
me to speak out against the stigma he
has faced as an autistic young person in
Pakistan
and I could go on and on and on with
others who have shared their lived
experience of disability in books
speeches blogs podcasts and social media
when you're looking for ways to make
your work more inclusive seek out the
voices of persons with disabilities
really take the time to listen to what
they have to say and follow their lead
disability has always been and will
always be a part of my life
Aaron and I deserve to live in a world
where she has more opportunities to be
supported and included
Aaron Ben Brina and haseeb are only four
out of over a billion people who are
just trying to find belonging and live
their best lives in a world that was not
designed for them indeed a world that
was designed to hold them back
not because it had to be that way but
because people built systems around
attitudes that other and exclude them
and all of those people have family
members like me whose lives are shaped
by this issue and communities who are
affected whether they realize it or not
disability inclusion is not something
nice that we do for those people
it is something critical that needs to
come from all of us thank you
[Applause]